[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUNJAN AGGARWAL: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this session.
I'm Gunjan Aggarwal.
I lead the Analytics and
Artificial Intelligence
practice for Capgemini
based out of New York.
Very, very super
excited to be here,
and would love to share what
we are working on, especially
in the fraud analytics area.
The way we have divided
the session is we
will first start with what
are the current market
challenges in the area of data
compromise, fraud analytics,
card not present, common
point of purchase.
Followed by, why Capgemini?
What is the value
addition we have done
in building these solutions?
And then why we have chosen the
Google Analytics, Google Cloud
Platform.
So with a combination of
Capgemini business intelligence
plus the technology
from the Google,
how we have come up with this
comprehensive fraud analytics
solution.
And the last, the second
half of the session, we
have a demo, which one of my
colleagues, Data Scientist
Jules, is going to present.
To begin with,
the first point is
why we are talking
about fraud analytics.
It's been happening
from a long time.
We assume that there
are already the systems.
The technology is in place.
Then why we are talking
about fraud analytics still?
There are certain stats,
which I wanted to bring in,
just to set up the context that
what is happening in this area.
There are predictions that
by 2020, card fraud worldwide
is expected to mushroom to
a total of approximately $32
billion.
It's a huge financial
loss to the organizations.
2/3 of the frauds
are suffered because
of card not present
transactions, which
can be easily avoided by using
a hybrid approach of machine
learning and a
rule-based approach.
47 of these frauds
which are happening--
these credit card frauds--
are actually happening
in the United States.
And every retailer-- on
the average, the retailers
are dealing with, per month,
approximately 442 fraud
attempts.
There is a financial loss.
The loss is not just because
of the credit card loss--
the frauds which are happening.
It's the operation loss too.
A lot of manpower
is required to go
through each and
every transaction,
monitor them, and reduce
the false positives.
What are the trends related
to data compromises?
There are four categories
I have bucketed.
The first one is frequency,
magnitude, sophistication,
and organization.
What does this mean?
If I go with the frequency
and magnitude first,
it means the frauds are
happening very frequently
with a large impact.
As I said, the impact is not the
money loss between these frauds
when it is happening.
It's the operation loss.
The current system, there is
a high false positive rate.
Because of this
high false positive,
there is a manpower
which is required
to go through each
and every alert
which the system has generated.
So that's the reason the
frequency and the magnitude
are the worst, I would
say, enemies of the data
compromises.
The next one is sophistication.
The fraudsters are
much more smarter.
They know how to tackle
that rule-based approach.
What they are doing
is they are coming up
with new and different ways
of committing these frauds.
The algorithms
what they are using
are very sophisticated--
very difficult to catch.
And because of that, what we
require in our existing fraud
system, they should be
able to customize based
on these new emerging trends.
But what is happening,
the way these solutions
are integrated there is
the making of customization
to that adds a lot of delay
in the time to market.
That's where the Capgemini has
partnered with Google Cloud
Platform to come up with a
solution which actually make
easy way of doing customization
and reduce the time to market.
The last one is organization.
The frauds are not just
limited to external.
The frauds are not
limited to what
may be happening on the
terminals, ATM, branches.
There is lot of internal
fraud which is happening,
the internal fraud done
by the internal staff,
in the internal processes,
and on the internal terminals.
So that is what we call
as an insider threat.
So these are the four main
buckets where the data
compromises are happening.
Now what is CPP?
For today's session,
we are mainly
focused on the common
point of purchase.
The solution we
have built is around
how this, on the
various terminals,
the compromise is happening.
So what is that?
It means when the fraudster
is using the skimming devices
on the cash machines or
the point-of-sale devices
to collect information
about the cards.
You are going to Wal-Mart,
you are going to Target--
there might be some machine
where the fraudsters have put
this type of a skimming device.
You are swiping your
cards, and your information
is getting collected.
That particular terminal becomes
the common point of purchase,
and when you see
there is a trend
happening that a
lot of customers
are complaining
on having a fraud.
And most of them are swiping on
that particular terminal, that
is what we call as to
uncover the CPP, which
is required to uncover the
fraud which is happening.
How we can handle that?
By analyzing the transactional
data at a regular basis.
A CPP algorithm can collect
a lot of information-- a lot
of insights.
Tracing, for instance, tracing
where these cards are getting
swiped.
What is the geolocation?
The demographic information
about the customers.
Identifying all the terminals
where this fraud is happening.
And providing a list of at-risk
cards so the detection is--
OK, if the fraud
has happened, we
know that these are the
10 cards or 20 cards
or hundreds of cards which
are getting compromised.
But how we can do
the prevention?
How we can identify
proactively which are
the cards which are at risk?
Our existing solutions are
more rule-based approach.
When a customer
complains or there
is an anomaly in the
transaction, it sends an alert.
But sometimes because,
as they are rule-based,
the false positives
is very high.
Finding exactly the
terminal-- finding
it more proactive,
more faster, is not
possible in the
existing systems.
Now what can be done when
this type of frauds happen?
One is sending the right
alert to the merchant,
that at this
particular terminal,
there is a skimming device that
customers' card information are
getting compromised.
The second one is that a
way the banks are handling
is, they change the cards.
But it's a very
expensive affair.
Changing the card, sending
the new cards to the customers
is very, very expensive
to the organization.
That's why it is very
important that not only be
reactive in fraud
analytics, but it also
be very important to
be proactive in finding
where this compromise
is getting happen.
Now about our solution.
As I said, we have partnered
with Google Cloud Platform.
We have come up with a
comprehensive solution that
is helping our client detect,
prevent, and analyze fraud
by using a hybrid approach--
machine learning along
with a rule-based approach.
Now how we have
come up with that?
As Capgemini
Financial Services, we
have multiple banking customers
from both issuing side
and acquiring side.
We did the whole assessment.
What is the current scenario?
What are the current
gaps in the system--
fraud solutions?
What is the business need?
And after talking to a lot
of folks in these banks,
we have come up with a
different business needs.
What the solution currently
exists, and what are the gaps
and how we can fill by building
a new solution on Google Cloud
Platform.
So to begin with, what
is a business need?
First, everyone wants to
reduce false positive.
There is lot of noise in
a rule-based approach.
Because of this noise, the
false positives increase.
And there is a whole
lot of team which
is sitting, going manually
each and every transaction,
and figuring out
whether it's really
a fraud or a false positive.
So first, everyone wants to
reduce the false positive.
Second, detect the fraud
faster, before it impacted
the huge customer base.
As I said, by the time
the fraud happened,
they wait for the
complaint or any anomaly,
the fraudsters start using
and selling in the dark web
all the card information.
And large number of
customers are getting
impacted because of that.
The next one is moving the fraud
system to cloud environment.
If you wanted to make the
detection more faster, more
quicker, and using
a machine learning,
it's important to have more
cloud environment instead
of the on-prem environment.
The next one is
flexible pricing model.
This is one of our
key differentiators
of our solution.
The existing solutions are
very, very tightly coupled.
If you wanted to
have a menu card
of where the customers
can pick and choose
based on their need--
that I need these components--
maybe network and analysis,
Customer 360, anomaly
detection, or insider threat.
That type of a facility is
not available in the existing
solution.
They are so coupled.
Because of that, they
are very expensive.
What we have created is we
have created a menu card which
we are giving to our customers.
They pick and choose
based on your need.
Don't change your
existing ecosystem.
existing architecture.
Pick up these accelerators, make
it part of your architecture,
and make it more smarter.
So that reduce
the time to market
and make the
decisions more faster.
And that's the beauty of cloud
environment and especially
Google Cloud Platform.
The next one is automation.
As I said, going through each
transaction, a lot of manpower
is required.
There is a department which goes
through each and every alert.
How we can automate the process?
How we can highlight or send
the right alerts to the end
customers, and the right
folks in the banks?
So the automation--
the workflows
are very, very important
in this solution.
The next is enhancing
the customer
behavior profiles and
uncover hidden relationships.
When we talk about the
customer, and especially
if you have to figure
out the location where
these terminals exist,
it's very important
to use the third-party
information of geolocation.
So we have partnered with some
data providers who give us
a zip code plus four information
so that we can drill down--
exactly pinpoint
where, which terminal,
this fraud is happening.
And not only that, we have
integrated our Customer 360
solution in it, where we create
a holistic view of the customer
to understand how they
are swiping these cards.
Because it gives us
information that, OK,
if this terminal at
this particular retailer
has compromise,
there is a chance
that next 50 customers
are going to swipe there,
because that's a trend.
That's about a Customer 360.
So creating that whole
transaction information,
their personal information--
creating one, more than an MDM,
that's what we create a holistic
view of the end customers.
So these are the
six business needs
which get highlighted
by our financial service
organizations.
And based on that, we come up
with our fraud analytics CPP
solution.
Now in this CPP solution,
we have five components.
First, how to do fraud
detection faster.
Find the fraud
transaction by location.
As I said, we are drilling
down into zip code plus four,
figuring out where exactly
it is happening so that we
can create a zone and find
that who all customers are
more likely to swipe
in next five days.
That is where our system is of
a solution is more proactive
and helps the organization
in taking decisions faster.
Next is network analysis.
So this is a very
nice component,
which Jules is
going to demo, where
we create a complete network
analysis of the retailers
and the customers.
This is visually able to
help the teams in the bank
to figure out who are
the next customers who
are going to in that.
If customers are
swiping at Place A,
who are going to
swipe at Place B too?
All this network
analysis is going
to help in detecting the frauds.
Fraud prevention-- as I said,
the financial loss is not
can be overcome just
by the fraud detection.
You have to be proactive
in your approach.
And the other components, the
machine learning components--
we have added the
network analysis--
help us figuring out where
exactly in next 10 days
there is a possibility
of the fraud.
And all these solutions
which I'm mentioning
is not just, I
would say, limited
to financial organization.
If you would take telecom,
if you take retails,
or any other industry
in the health care,
the components, the way
we have designed it,
can be leveraged with
certain customization
in any of the vertical.
The last one is machine learning
models and cloud capabilities.
We have taken a rule-based
hybrid approach here.
The existing solutions
where are rule,
we have actually applied a
hybrid and machine learning
model.
And it also has a voting
system, which in detail, Jules
is going to discuss.
In the real time,
the algorithm which
is giving more accuracy
getting picked up out
of that high voting system
of the machine learning.
Now having these
five components,
what are the benefits
we bring on the table?
The first one is
mitigating fraud.
That's our first objective.
Reducing manual
intervention-- once you
have less false positive,
the manual intervention
will drastically reduce.
Faster action-- faster
decisions by the organization.
And these actions can be from
an issuing side, the banks,
or even the acquiring banks.
The merchants--
even the retailers
can take the action the way we
have come up with the CPP score
in our solution.
Reduce false positives
and scalability--
so scalability, as
I mentioned, there
is a frequency and a huge
impact of these frauds.
You have to regularly
checked the pulse.
The pulse can be
regularly checked
if the solution is scalable.
And that's where
the Google Cloud
Platform is helping us in making
our solution more scalable.
Now why GCP is important
for the fraud analytics?
Why we have picked up the
Google Cloud Platform?
The first one is the fraud
analytics require huge storage
services.
For initial model building, a
local data lake of transaction
must be processed.
You need to train your model
based on the historical data.
And luckily, the
Google has the ability
to connect you directly to
the network with a lightning
fast upload speed.
So we come up with
all the parameters
which are the must-have
for a platform.
And one of it, as I mentioned,
that huge storage device
services, which Google
was providing to us.
And once the platform
is up and running,
the services we
are building must
be able to automatically
scale and match
the number of transactions
which are happening every day.
And that's where
the Google Cloud
Platform plays a major role.
It gives us a very scalable
option of our solution.
The second one-- TPUs,
the faster processing.
And yesterday, we all know
Google has made announcement
about their TPUs.
As we have a voting system of
the machine learning model,
the algorithm should be able
to detect the fraud faster.
That's where the TensorFlow
processing units,
and scalable VM
instances are helping us
in fast delivery of computations
in both static and real-time
situations.
And speed is one of the crucial
aspects of the fraud detection.
Any delay leads to a huge
impact on the customer.
More and more customers
get impacted if there
is a delay in detection
of this fraud.
Third, we need a
front end application.
We wanted to make it very,
very user-friendly application
so that it is not just limited
to the technical people.
Even the business users
can use that application,
and in near- to
real-time can see
what is happening, if there is
any alert, where the fraud is
happening, which terminal it is,
who all customers are getting
impacted.
And if they can connect
it with the email system,
they can shoot out
the emails quickly.
So for that front
end application
to be very easily
deployable and customizable,
the App Engine of the Google
gives us that flexibility.
That environment offers
us seamless integration
with various other APIs
so that the development
team don't waste their time
learning a new language.
They can drag and drop.
They can immediately host the
applications of the services
on the platform.
The last but not the least,
the rule-based model,
we all know the
limitations of it.
And as I said, we need a
heavy lifting machine learning
model for the fraud detection.
And Google Cloud Platform,
having a dedicated machine
learning engine service for
deployment, version management,
and hyperparameter
tuning, helped us
in tweaking and
development faster.
All the models--
the complete model
lifecycle from the development
to productionisation,
that's where the GCP plays
a very important role.
So these were some
of the parameters
which we were doing the
assessment at which platform
worked best, and that's where
the Google Cloud Platform fit
into the requirement.
And we partnered with them in
building this Fraud Analytics
CPP solution.
Next, why Capgemini?
As I said, in Capgemini,
we are a consulting firm.
We have that business scenario.
We know the business
requirement.
We work very closely with
the financial organization's
various different verticals to
understand the business need.
And to do that, what
we have come up with--
we have two Applied
Innovation Exchange--
an accelerated
solution environment.
What we do in Applied
Innovation Exchange--
that is open for our customers.
Where we bring our customers,
we transform their ideas
into the reality
in a faster speed.
We work with them closely.
We bring our own accelerators
through ACE platform,
which we keep building
in our lab in Capgemini
so that it brings their
dream into the reality much
more quicker.
For the machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
we have our own
frameworks, which
we have deployed so far
to multiple customers,
and they are successfully able
to make the whole enterprise
more AI powered.
From the [INAUDIBLE] to the
NLP to the email classification
and various other
financial advisor genome,
there are multiple solutions
we have built in our platform
with our partners and which
we have already deployed
to different customers.
The next one is market trend.
We continue to keep doing
a lot of assessment,
not just from our
customer perspective,
but overall market
trends, which help us
in understanding proactively
where the market is trending.
What the future is.
contact center
future, let's take,
or the organization
future, marketing future.
So we work very proactively
with our customers
to bring the
changes and to bring
that impact into their firms.
And last, with
having an expertise
in different
verticals, working with
different financial
organizations,
we know what is required.
Especially in the AI
area, what can sail?
That's the most important thing.
We all talk about
AI machine learning.
But what doesn't work
is very important.
We know all the dos and don'ts,
which we bring it on the table
in our engagements.
And that's what
Capgemini adds as a value
to the fraud analytic
solution we have built.
Now time for the demo.
I'm handing over
to Jules, who is
a data scientist in Capgemini.
JULES DECOURTENAY:
Hey, everyone.
My name's Jules DeCourtenay.
I'm the Lead Data
Scientist and Solution
Architect for this project.
And so I've been on the project
from inception until now.
And I'm also the tallest
data scientist in the world.
So the total project is broken
up into three main areas.
We have the computing and
the processing side, the data
and how it's stored, and
then the front end and output
side of things.
So we used Compute Engine
on the Google Cloud
to host various virtual machines
running Python on Datalab,
where we could then build
our rules-based algorithms.
From there, once we were
happy with that, we feature
engineered from about
15 or 18, I think,
features into
upwards of hundreds.
Once we were happy, we then
trained three different machine
learning models and put those
into a voting classifier,
because we were really trying to
squeeze as much out of the data
as we could.
The voting classifier
picks the best model
for each different transaction,
so you're getting the best
prediction every single time.
We uploaded the data
onto cloud storage
and then imported
that into BigQuery
so we could run our SQL
and different Python
algorithms on that.
In real time, the data will come
out from the bank's mainframe
into the cloud.
So we could run pulse checks
on the different frequency
of fraud, send predictions back,
and then also archive that data
securely on the cloud for future
training and stuff like that.
So the front end side, we used
App Engine Flexible Environment
to host the web app.
It was a Python flask server.
And we did that because it
gives us frequent system
reports, seamless integration
with the back end,
it's very secure, and
it's got easy maintenance
with automated log files,
version deployment, and version
regression as well.
So enough talking,
let's get to the demo.
This is the web app.
As I said, it's
hosted on App Engine.
And so this is the OAuth
2.0 authentication service.
I'm sure everyone's
familiar with this--
have seen this sort of
login button before.
And it is tied in with the
GCP IAM, or Identity Access
Management System.
So you can specify
which employees
you want to have access to
different parts of the project.
So I'm an owner of the
project, so it's asking me
if I want it to access
my BigQuery data,
which is exactly
what I want it to do.
So I login and it sends me
to this splash screen where
I can see exactly where I
want to go on the web app,
depending on the use case
that I have of being here.
So picture me.
I'm sitting in a bank, and I'm
looking at the current credit
card fraud climate, and
I want to investigate
what's going on right now
amongst all of our customers.
So I click Dashboard.
This is showing me
the spread of where
our customers are
spending their money
and how they're spending it.
So you can see here, this
is the most used card type.
We can see that
mass credit cards,
along with point-of-sale
channel transactions,
are the most popular.
They have the biggest market
share in those metrics.
That's perfect, because that's
what our CPP algorithms are
targeting.
We're targeting those
because we're trying
to minimize this failure rate.
Sitting at 10%-- that means
10% of all of our clients'
transactions, we're having
to lose money because we're
having a chargeback on those.
So keeping that in mind, I want
to do something about that.
So I can click the
Fraud Detection button,
and that brings me to
the Fraud Detection page.
Immediately, I can see
today's fraud index.
That is a metric that
updates in real time,
depending on how much fraud
our systems are picking up.
So it's going to be
oscillating up and down.
I put these buttons in
here just to indicate how
that would change during a day.
And so right now, it's
sitting at 80 out of 100,
which means there's a lot of
action going on out there.
The fraudsters are
active doing their thing.
And since it's so high, and
the average fraud transaction
amount is $530, it means
we're losing a lot of money.
So in these
transactions right here,
that's where we're
losing the money.
Once again, I'm trying to
do something about that.
That's the reason I'm here.
So I'm going to investigate.
I see that there was this
peak here on day 166.
Our data went from
day zero to day 180,
so that was 14 days ago.
And using the
Google Charts API, I
can actually zoom
in on that peak,
just to get some more
insight into what's going on.
And then when I click
that, this is telling me
what percentage of
those transactions
our fraud system
picked up and denied,
and then what percentage
it didn't and we actually
had to charge back.
That's where we're
losing the money.
So keeping that in mind, I
want to investigate further
by looking at the actual
points of compromise.
So as I said, that's day
166, which is two weeks ago--
14 days.
And so the whole point of
CPP is that you can actually
change the time
window that you want
the algorithm to look back.
Right now it's
looking back two days,
so the customers that went
to merchants two days prior.
And if I move that, I can
actually change the time window
to 14 days.
So then this gives me a
list of every merchant
that we believe
could be compromised,
sorted in probability.
And then it also
gives me the list.
Once I click that,
it gives me the list
of clients or customers
sorted in the same order.
So I can click the
top client, and it
tells me it's John Smith.
This is just a splash page
of all of the information
that we have on him.
You can see his balance.
He's got $2,000 in his account.
His credit score is 145,
so he's not doing too hot.
Just a whole bunch
of information,
account transaction history.
But this is an important number.
Here is the fraud score.
That's a number that
we actually assign
to him based on the
likelihood that we
think his information is going
to be used illegally soon.
So since I know that his
fraud score is eight,
so I already want to
investigate further.
I want to see what
merchants he's
been to, and then the different
other customers that have also
been to those merchants.
So I can see these small circles
represent different account
holders that we have, and then
the big circles are obviously
the merchants that
they've been to.
So I can see John Smith.
So this is his fraud score.
It's eight still.
He's that little
circle there, and he's
been to Best Buy, Target,
Walgreens, Al's Toy Store.
And so if I want to
see, basically, Apple.
So he went to Apple and Apple's
compromise probability is 0.9,
so we're already really sure
that the terminal at that Apple
Store--
someone's fiddled
with that and they're
stealing people's information.
Just to investigate further,
I click another account,
and I can see their
fraud score is at a two.
So even though Apple's
compromise probability
is a 0.9, that
doesn't necessarily
mean that their taking
everyone's information,
because not everyone is
vulnerable right now.
So that's just another
way of drawing connections
between merchants
and customers, even
to the second degree
of the other customers.
This is a dump of
all the affected
transactions that our
systems are picking up.
Me as a user, I can
just look at that
and see trends
maybe in category.
And then this graph right
here-- it's a little bit busy,
but it's the total turnover,
so the amount of money
our customers are
spending at merchants
based on the categories.
So since we've already been
investigating and looking
at Apple, I want to
see that day 166 again.
What's been going on
in the tech category?
So I think this color
is tech right here.
That's day 166, so there
was a bit of a peak there.
And since it was a
$3,000 transaction only,
usually tech products
are fairly expensive.
You know, you buy like a phone
or a computer or something
like that.
$3,000 is maybe only
a few purchases,
so that could be one swipe
of a fraudulent swipe made
by a fraudster.
So this whole time, we're
just taking information
in from so many
different sources
and starting to
build this picture.
OK, so the whole time in
the background, our systems
are working to detect the fraud.
Even though right now
I'm looking at this,
it's always working
in the cloud.
And I put this
button in here just
to sort of indicate when
our system detects a fraud.
It would pop up
with this banner,
and it would follow me around
until I click Detected.
So then that brings me down to
this attention-grabbing little
box, where me as a user, I
can start to take action.
I can get all the
crucial information
that I need in the most
efficient and effective way
to start to make decisions
and do something about it.
So I can see this is the
alert, ID tied with that.
It was a $5,000 transaction.
I can look further
into the customer.
So it was John Smith.
We had applied that
eight fraud score to him,
and then he ended up having
his information used illegally.
And the merchant, it was Apple.
So based on all of that
information that we've
been looking at, we already sort
of knew that this would happen.
And I can even click
Apple's address,
and this brings me to the fraud
transaction by location page.
This is a-- it's a Google
Maps API, integrated
with JavaScript, and it
can populate based on fraud
that we're picking up in
different areas in the world.
It can start to populate
and create hotspots.
So you can see the Apple
Store was in New York City.
So this is New York right here.
That's already a hotspot.
That's what our system's
already been picking up.
Now unfortunately, the data
that we were working with,
it was simulated from a
bank in one town in Spain.
So we are super confident
that moving forward,
we can easily populate
things like that
and then start to
build connections
between the actual
geographic location,
create hotspots, and then
their connections to CPP.
So this whole time, we've
been looking at fraud
after the fact-- more of a
reactive approach to things.
Let's switch things up.
And we're going to change to
a more proactive approach.
So this right here,
in my opinion,
this is one of the most
important, informative metrics
on the entire demo.
So it has two different
sources of information.
The histogram is showing
us the fraud count
or the number of fraud
transactions associated
with that merchant.
And then the line graph is
showing the average amount
of time after one
of our customers
visits that merchant, to when
their information is stolen.
So this gives us a lot
of power, because we
can start to look into
same day-- industry
first, same day detection.
But I know that
these two merchants
right here, when
our customers visit
them, within the next
day, their information
is going to be used illegally.
And the same goes
for different times.
This is 12 days.
I can click that, and I can
already start to take action.
I'm sitting at my desk at the
office, and I can take action.
I can give Fred's
Hardware Store a call.
I can send an
investigator out there
to actually look
at the terminal.
Or I can alert every
customer that's been there
and let them know, hey, keep
an eye out on your account.
Same goes for customers.
So we have a just
another dump here
of likelihood or
probability of fraud
happening to these accounts.
And I can click the customer.
I see it's Sean Price.
Same thing, give him a call,
send him a text or an email,
depending on what we
have on their account,
along with the actual
specific use case of the bank.
Or we can suspend
the account outright
because we're so
sure that we're going
to be losing money soon anyway.
So once again, we are
super confident with how
our system has performed.
That should we get some more
dense information, some more
things about the fraud
and the transactions,
we'll be able to extend into
branch ID fraud, and even
staff ID fraud.
So that's looking at
more internal threats.
And then also location, so we
could start to put together
these hotspots around the
globe, where when we find out
a customer is entering,
say, a street that is known
for fraudulent activity,
we can send them a text
and they look on their phone and
it says, hey, keep an eye out.
Stuff like that.
So moving to the system
performance page.
The last thing here.
I just wanted to show you guys
the limitations of the data
that we had.
So this is the number of
fraudulent transactions
for every day.
Out of 180 days,
the simulator only
injected exactly
40 for every day.
So obviously that's not
necessarily reflective of what
would happen in real
life, but we were still
able to extract such
meaningful information
and such meaningful
metrics that we're
really confident that
with some better data,
the sky's the limit, basically.
[MUSIC PLAYING]